strong winds are blowing again in
California and that's very bad news for
millions of people hoping to avoid some
of the most destructive wildfires the
state has ever seen
two of those fires have burned nearly
200 thousand acres an area about the
size of New York City
they are blamed for at least 31 deaths
the fires in the north and south have
forced a quarter of a million people to
evacuate their homes six more bodies
were found overnight near the camp fire
in Northern California now that brings
its death toll to 29 matching the
deadliest fire in state history more
than 200 people are still unaccounted
for and more than six thousand homes
have been destroyed in Southern
California the woolsey fire has killed
two people there and burned more than
170 homes CBS Evening News anchor Jeff
Glor leads our coverage from Calabasas
California that's on the western edge of
Los Angeles Jeff good morning Gail good
morning to you it is a grim grim scene
across so much of California today this
is just one of the many many homes that
has been destroyed you can see the ash
smoke in the air this one is this fire
still smoldering here this morning we
want to show you what this neighborhood
looked like on Friday as this woolsey
fire ripped through here so quickly
this is cell phone video taken in this
neighborhood we're standing in right now
these flames indiscriminate
taking down so many homes and there is
new concern this morning winds began
picking up again overnight we got a gust
of 58 miles an hour threatening to undo
the progress that firefighters made over
the weekend last night officials ordered
all of the nearly 25,000 people who live
here in Calabasas to evacuate
more than 8,000 firefighters are
battling the flames tearing across
California the scenes are horrendous in
Malibu the Woolsey fire ripped through
celebrity mansions and suburban
neighborhoods welcome to my home in
Malibu actor Gerard Butler returned home
to find rubble and ashes officials
warned nearly 60,000 homes and
businesses could be in danger do not
stay in your homes to try and defend
them please leave that to us
the fame Zuma Beach became a staging
area for people and their animals
fleeing the fire with the fresh air come
in at least you have fresh air coming
off the beach because of the ocean
because let me tell you it was so the
air was so thick last night you could
barely breathe we have a real challenge
here threatening our whole way of life
California Governor Jerry Brown has
asked President Trump for extra
resources after declaring a major
disaster Sunday the governor spoke a day
after the president tweeted a message
appearing to blame the California
government for recent wildfires the
union that represents the majority of
firefighters in this state push back
labeling the comments insulting and
reckless it's a time to pull together
and work through this tragedy things
like this will be part of our future
things like this and worse the hell fire
which is just west of here is 75 percent
contained now because of that and the
Woolsey fire here are being investigated
wind gusts this week forecast to hit as
high as 70 miles an hour again we
mentioned we get a gust this morning at
58 miles an hour that is what makes
these fires so dangerous they can spread
so quickly it also threatens to grunt
helicopters and planes which used to
drop water forcing crews to fight these
flames solely from the ground which
makes it so much more difficult